and the earth is bluff flat the earth is
flat
my reality my senses tell me that the
earth is flat flat earthers
antibacters and moon landing skepticists
are often seen as a memes of the
internet
people are often quick to write off
these individuals as uneducated
gullible idiots but why exactly do flat
earthers even believe in a flat earth
and where did their arguments go wrong
[Music]
well before we get into their arguments
as to why the earth is flat
let's take a quick look at what exactly
they believe
the most common flat earth perspective
is that the arctic is in the center of
the disk
and all the continents are spread out
around the arctic circle
meanwhile antarctica marks boundary of
the disk
and nasa guards are apparently guarding
antarctica so that people don't travel
to the edge of the disk
and discover the truth as for what's
underneath the disk
the consensus is that it's just rocks
this actually makes a lot more sense
before making this video
i thought flat earthers simply thought
that the earth looked like a regular old
world map
that made no sense at all as a flight
from california to japan in a
respectable amount of time
was basically impossible the arctic in
the center of the disc theory
does address this issue but it still has
one fatal flaw
a flight from the tip of south america
to australia would take an absurdly long
amount of time
in other words though this theory makes
more sense conceptually
it doesn't add up proportionally
whatsoever as for the sun
and the moon flat earth has claimed that
both the sun and the moon are spheres
with the 32 mile diameter these spheres
are positioned 3 000 miles above the
face of the earth
and move around in circles kind of like
a spotlight
this is actually really ironic as they
believe that the sun
and the moon are spheres but for some
reason the earth isn't
anyways as for the lunar cycle the flat
earth society wiki suggests that the sun
and moon are wobbling up and down when
circling the disk
when the moon's altitude is lower than
that of the sun we see a new moon
conversely when the moon's altitude is
higher than that of the sun
we see a full moon but what about lunar
and solar eclipses
well they think that there is an
invisible anti-moon that is
also circling the earth which will
occasionally cover up the sun and the
moon
that's the basic mechanics of the flat
earth theory but
there are a few more concerns that we
should address like gravity
in reality we know that gravity is the
innate attraction between
all bodies of mass within the flat earth
universe though
the gravitational force is caused by the
flat earth system
infinitely accelerating upwards at 9.81
meters per second squared
and this upwards acceleration is caused
by something called
dark energy here's the thing though if
the earth was actually accelerating
upwards at 9.81 meters per second
squared
it would only take a year for the earth
to reach the speed of light
according to national geographic the
earth has been around for 4.54 billion
years
which would mean that the earth is
currently traveling upwards at
approximately
4.68 billion times the speed of light
anyways amongst a plethora of other
concerns
the last concern we'll cover is how
planes and gps work
the flat earth society claims that all
gps's are rigged
and the pilots think they're going in a
straight line but really they're
actually just going around in circles
as you can see all of this is quite
far-fetched
however the flat earth society is still
very much a real thing
so why do people continue to buy into
this theory
well there is some logic to it
one of the most common flower arguments
is that skyscrapers don't disappear into
the horizon
as they move away from them take this
picture of chicago skyline for instance
the given picture was taken 60
kilometers from the coast of chicago
as a result you shouldn't be able to see
the skyscrapers
but clearly you can and no
the flat earthers didn't do their math
wrong given the curvature of the earth
and height of the skyscrapers
you shouldn't be able to see the skyline
from 60 kilometers from the coast
but taking a look at this picture it
doesn't even seem like the skyline is
starting to disappear into the horizon
though this might make one question the
shape of the earth there is of course
a physics explanation for this
phenomenon light travels
at a different speed through warm and
cold air
which causes the light to bend as it
travels from one to the other
one of the basic principles of
convection is that warm air rises
and cooler sinks causing cool air to
settle at the surface
and warm air to settle higher up
considering this
whenever you look at the top of a
skyscraper the light is traveling
through progressively cooler air
as it reaches your eyes causing the
light to bend towards the surface
of the earth consequently the top of the
skyscraper is visible for much longer
than you might have originally
anticipated
this is also the same reason you can see
a boat traveling out into the ocean for
much longer than you might think
another popular experiment that flower
authors use to justify their position
is a bunch of laser experiments if you
go onto the fly earth society website
and look at their evidence list
you'll see a bunch of different laser
experiments with varying distances
the idea is that you set up a laser in
some given location
at a specific height let's say 5 feet
then you go several miles out and place
a white board or little hole
at the same height if the earth is
indeed a sphere
the laser shouldn't hit the exact same
height as it was emitted
according to many flower experiments
though the laser ends up hitting the
same height
now i'm not really sure what they're
doing here to get these results
either they're conducting the experiment
wrong or they're lying about the results
because they can't replicate the results
on camera
in a netflix documentary called behind
the curve
netflix would invite a couple of flower
activists to conduct the experiment
on camera in this show the experiment
was a bit different using a camera and a
light
as opposed to a light and a board but it
uses the same principle
if the light and camera are at the same
height the camera should pick up the
light
but guess what it didn't work
something that was even more funny is
that one of the guys would lift up the
light
and would appear on the camera so
ironically
the flat earthers just proved the earth
was a globe on camera
after this failure the flat earther
would simply comment quote
that's interesting moving on we have the
last major reason
many individuals are swayed to believe
in the flat earth
which is various verses in religious
text specifically the bible
over the years flat earthers have
compiled a variety of bible verses that
supposedly suggest that the earth is
flat
for instance the bible states quote
after this
i saw four angels standing at the four
corners of the earth
holding back the four winds of the earth
to prevent any wind from blowing on the
land
or on the sea or on any tree many
similar statements are also taken out of
the quran
and other religious scriptures as well
you can't really disprove these
statements
but it's usually very clear that such
evidence is generally taken
out of context and understood on a
literal basis
so in the end most flowers are logic is
derived from scientific experiments
which seem promising
but are actually flawed or they're
derived from literal understandings of
religious text
really though all this logic is just
surface reasoning
the real reasoning for flat earth is not
experiments or religious text
the root reasoning behind fly earth
logic is a lack of trust of the
establishment
here's the thing most flyers logic has
spurred from the use of the synthetic
method
as opposed to the scientific method the
scientific method encourages collecting
data and conducting experiments
in order to form a conclusion with this
attack method though
it's basically the opposite one is
encouraged to make observations first
and then find empirical data to prove
the original observation
clearly this is not a very robust method
of deduction
moreover scientists discovered that the
earth is indeed a sphere
thousands of years ago aristotle who
lived in the 300s bce
was able to deduct that the earth was
spherical through various astrological
observations
and since then scientists around the
world have come to the same conclusion
through a variety of different methods
by the time christopher columbus sailed
the ocean blue
virtually all educated individuals knew
the earth was spherical
in fact the story that christopher
columbus set out to prove that earth was
round is completely false the reason
that various kings didn't want to fund
columbus's journey
is because they thought his travel time
frame was extremely wrong
columbus thought that he could make the
journey in months
while the king's advisor suggested that
it would take well over a year
the king's advisors were actually
technically right
where they went wrong though was not
knowing that there was a huge piece of
land
between spain and china anyways
as you can see flat earthers versus
globe birthers is not an age-old battle
like you might have come to believe
ironically the vast majority of modern
flowers theory was developed and spread
within the last 200 years
you see throughout the 1800s many
individuals disliked the rapid
scientific progress that was occurring
and they wanted to return to the basics
so
they encouraged people to make their own
observations and come to their own
conclusions
one such influencer was a writer named
samuel robitham
he would write about an arctic centered
earth that was flat and this would be
one of the first resurgences of the
flower theory
in thousands of years this mode of
thought would grow
over the next several decades and in
samuel shenton would set up the
international flowers research society
dedicated to finding evidence that the
earth is indeed flat unlike we've been
told
at the end of the day why are flat
earther is still a thing
well it's not because of lasers or
skyscrapers or the bible
the primary reason flat earthers are
still around is biggest of mistrust
of the establishment no amount of
evidence will prove handy in disproving
this logic
and as long as there's a lack of trust
the flat earth community will continue
to thrive what do you guys think is the
main reason
flat earthers have surged over the past
few decades comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys enjoyed
this explanation
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]
you